astrid a 20 ans et à trice 15 ans et
leur frère yves 17 ans trois témoins
parmi d'autres des dégâts causés par le
distilbène
tous trois sont atteints de
malformations des organes génitaux leur
mère d'anne avait reçu durant ces
grossesses cette hormone soi-disant
contre les fausses couches
aujourd'hui dan entend regrouper les
deux cent mille femmes qui ont pris du
distilbène
après des années de culpabilité dan a
décidé de faire tomber le tabou
l'imam on n'ose pas dire à leurs
mensonges et dim allemande qui se
manifeste et qui me dit comment je dois
faire et ce que je dois le dire est ce
que tu vas pas le dire et se
culpabiliser toujours et ça il faut il
faut plus assez confiance déjà 1000
femmes au sein de l'association des
victimes du distilbène
elles ne comprennent pas pourquoi ce
médicament n'a été retiré du marché
qu'en 77,6 ans après les états unis
aujourd'hui outre le risque de
malformations génitales une femme
exposée sur quatre ne parvient pas à
mettre au monde d'enfants vivent les
gynécologues prennent enfin ce problème
au sérieux
l'électricien a fait une enquête
montrant bien que les conséquences en
france selon lui même aux états unis il
faut donc rendu précaution et il ya
maintenant une liste devant élaborer
deux médecins qui sont prêts à prendre
en charge tout spécialement ses passes
la brochure pour les médecins projet de
résolution au parlement européen
les choses sont en train de bouger même
si pourim les semaines ça signifiait
cette opération 7
cette opération au final je ne sais pas
encore quand